pai eu acho que o mauro me instalou
entre várias pessoas com menos uma
letona sou mesmo branca do lubango o que
tem com um sapo fazer com vocês é
dizer-nos op o o alarme
vocês sabem sim é que eu sou do lubango
estamos a falar de um mundo
sejam bem-vindos é desconhecida da
intervenção do palco parece muito
oportuno ter ficado a fruta é seguir e
eu e formal é tudo aquilo que nós somos
nas cidades e em angola é é uma pulsão
ou seja é uma energia interior e e
intrínseca da nossa vida não só ganha e
formal e não sei que da outra idade da
cidade é do action amamos bairros alguns
ex não é nossa vida é completamente
informal e ainda bem por um lado da
imensa as vantagens e as quais temos de
buscar imensos recursos imensos
inteligências por uma razão muito
simples porque não sentir mais ligeiro e
quer dizer com certeza um estarreja
muito mais descontraído um star que
albergam sorrisos um estádio que tu eras
jesus
isso tudo estar ou nós podemos ir e
beber outras e inteligências que suas
fazem quando ainda suas águas conforto e
vão ter que buscar e vão ter que
inventar e vão ter que usar de uma
extrema criatividade informalidade é
isso
no bom sentido da palavra normalmente
entendida de uma maneira negativa num
numa autoridade depreciada tem a ver com
o outro e isto outro que de uma maneira
geral é um mito e rejeitada em graz ada
que o pai
de rádio do um zoom é que estava
responder algumas perguntas até bom
programa do que um que eu vou a e e e
curiosity um estudo esta é tão
inteligente esta esta coisa porque
realmente é que o que era suposto que
urbano fiz as pessoas era preparar nem
que você sua infraestrutura para que
suas poderia sem chegar nós poder ser eu
o receber
e é exatamente o contrário que acontece
nas cidades nestas nossas cidades são as
pessoas que chegam e o resto que nem
sabemos o quê que nem querer se dava é
que em contextos e encontrar as pessoas
gostaram do grande capital do que
acontece no chamado meio urbano e é fato
11 uma coisa que construída exatamente
por todas estas pessoas
os dados estatísticos sobre estas sobre
a informalidade digamos assim
ou seja definir formalizado como o 11
lugar sobretudo ao topo construídos e
sobretudo lugares que está em como sente
tradicional muette biologicamente
falando uma com uma outra coisa de uma
idéia qualquer de ordem que normalmente
é uma ideia de poder é uma idéia
construída dentro do mar
um outro conceito tradicionais de
vivência e do conceito tradicional de
oxidado é este twitter mas já
completamente atualizada no entanto é
que o nós o contexto urbano temos como
sendo o presente eo futuro do do urbano
tem muito pouco a ver com esta cidade
tradicional ou têm muito pouca vir
conhecer com essa coisa completamente
scoa da 30 anos chamam fazer planos
diretor cidadão que de todo não ser
vencida da promoção que um simples um
plano diretor mora há cinco anos esse
feito e 20 ser implantado o fim 20 anos
em cidades tão dinâmicas como a nossa
com uma população tão ativa quando a
coisa começa a ser implantada já toda a
população e toda uma dinâmica econômica
e devido
se ao outro e é configuração física do
território portanto eu estou em
trabalhar completamente jesus demodê
inútil por gastar dinheiro e nunca nos
vai servir para nada
isto que acontece conosco acontece no
mundo inteiro por 50 por cento do ônus
das populações mundiais vivem é não é
mais informais e quando estamos a falar
disto
naturalmente o sentido é dentro da
urbanidade
é verdade que o urbanizador já não é um
uno uma cisão entre campo e cidade a
todo o território que cuja interação
extraordinária e muito grande
dentre as proposições que vão
abandonando campo eo e esposas rurais
como disse o paulo tem que aprender e
saber é e com quem temos que aprender
com mantê las é viver lá com nós
próprios podemos lugar nos das cidades
para outras cidades intermédias ou menos
pela mesma e rurais ou então sabia como
as vilas com receber o que aprender com
elas como é que pessoas que vêm de uma
realidade podem viver ou podem servir
muito sua experiência pessoal e do seu
conhecimento com maio e diesel
naturalmente hostil esta realidade
mundial prevista que 2050 é com faça com
que 70% posição mundial vá viver em
cidades o que é absolutamente é forte ou
seja como um sentido à autoridade sobre
o que é a maioria do meio urbano mundial
160 posição mundial são milhões e
milhões de pessoas que constrói hoje as
suas vidas construir as suas vidas não
quer dizer o contrário do que é suposto
construir os seus lugares essenciais que
chamou sua habitação
não é toda uma vida uma vida cuja
economia é brilhante mas mantida por
elas que 80% da nossa economia nacional
visa daqui o que come
informal é sustentada pela icomi formal
do nosso petróleo só pagar as dívidas
externas e etc é nossa economia é
sustentada pela informalidade pelo
caminho normal e e dentro disso 80% dela
produtividade nomes sondados elemento
importante não com não consideramos isto
como alguma coisa que de fato a vida não
é e onde estão as informações as
inteligências criatividade obras que
todas as suas
estamos a falar falando do ano 4 milhões
e quinhentas pessoas
são essas pessoas que têm nos ensinar
coisas mas claro eu acho que a comida e
aqui preconceituosa e graves simples
sobre essa coisa de um seco sobre essa
coisa da informalidade é e assim a
emoção humana é uma coisa que os dias a
todo o respeito porque que é que com os
assusta é só estamos a pobreza estas
naturalmente é a imagem exterior ué cadê
é capa de muito da informalidade é uma
capa agressiva é uma capa com é pintada
que não é que não tenha cosmética e
assusta sobretudo uma outra coisa que
essa sim é extraordinariamente grave é a
ausência de uma bunda da infraestrutura
social e de infraestrutura sanitária que
é extremamente grave não é é é uma coisa
que nos faz rejeitar e charque
é o outro lado não sei bem qual é o
nosso avô não percebeu a esse ponto da
idéia que há uma outra coisa que não
cremos na universidade os meus alunos
não querem estudar o é cidade informal
não quer ir para dentro dos bairros
fazer trabalho de campo não querem saber
dizem todos os dias coisas absolutamente
horríveis tipo não tem conserto preta
destruir e acabada é para deitar fora é
que lhe muito mal e tu e suas tem 20
anos de quem é exposto ouvir frança
quanto mais os dirigentes querem ouvir
movimento rejeitar todos os dias
e já que é preliminar como se pudessem
seguir na vida o que está ali dentro
dentro do que os imensos bairros que
temos neste nossa cidade em todas as
cidades angolanas i é muito mundo é um
capital inicial de pessoas
eu vos principal uma infraestrutura
humana é uma estrutura do conhecimento
extremamente valiosa e isso muitas vezes
podemos provar algumas imagens urbanas
produz mostrar de que os preços urbanas
que essas próprias posições fazem ou
seja não fazem só que o painel equipe de
cenci ao refúgio mm imediato da casa
não não os três enviados criativas que
podemos ver em algumas imagens destas
muitas delas não são não são daqui temos
imagens aqui de vários de vários países
pressupunham capacidade podemos
trabalhar com outra identidade a comenda
com com um chamado à sustentabilidade
este termo masía da mente na moda e mal
emprega com materiais muitas vezes
reciclados com um banho que fosse
apresentado colorido de outra maneira
seria com certeza um grande défice tem
qualquer falha de design importante com
a capacidade de uma identidade de um
cálculo que fala de dentro de uma
identidade física associada com uma tia
uma cultura um modo o módulo de de vídeo
integrado do viveiro um cio habitar
cultural é que o que o habitar que essa
relação de equilíbrio com tudo que é
envolvendo o que essas pessoas têm para
nos ensinar tenta nos ensinar tudo
porque é preciso ter menor morreu dado e
é preciso não ser completamente autista
para pensar e quatro milhões e meio de
pessoas todos os dias conseguem garantir
o hoje construir
sim é não sejam pessoas de uma enorme
inteligência do menor lhe dada porque
somos isto fazem omoletes sem ovos não
tem água não tem luz não tem transporte
não têm trabalho
não não tem não tem montanhas enorme
capacidade de gerir essas ausências
quantos nós aqui sabemos se capazes
disto quantos nós seremos capazes de
conseguir gerir dead isso rindo e
lutando a vida todos os dias pra lento
dos heróis nós tínhamos
eu acho que essas pessoas devem também
ser nossos heróis
esse é extremamente importante porque
deus fazem e luta é luta em surf em
fazem a vida acontecer e sobretudo fazem
economia aconselho meus queridos amigos
é nossa economia é sustentada pela busca
aplicar de ficar eu nunca informal ano
porque nossa economia dominante em
completamente informal
então a morar aqui uma coisa que sempre
é muito estranha quer ver se os alunos
não querem estudar porque que esta
rejeição eterna dos poderosos porque
esta coisa de dizer não não é casada de
vida e cultura subterrânea e o saber
fazer as coisas e ter inventado dentro
de se inventar amanhã uma questão
essencial que é normal tem muito pouco
para lhes dar
se os governos simplesmente se os
abandonam e eles vivem de uma de uma
solidão em excepcional enorme desenho
suas vidas numa enorme solidariedade é
entre outros e todos os dias encontram
vai passar o esquema uma ligação direta
faz vida essas pessoas têm um capital é
de investigadores sobre o território com
os quais é preciso aprender
realmente inventar o futuro e aprender
outra coisa fundamental estudando
não há forma que falha não lixo que está
a fazer não é chapa ou um bloco de
cimento que está à vista e que de alguma
maneira criar uma orgia é assim
preconceituosa por parte das pessoas não
só pensar e se estes tipos comigo equipe
conseguiu levar a água estava a água
fazer a água distribuir a luz que vai da
puxada não sei da onda que vai pro rio
tempo continuou conseguiu contê fazer
com que o negócio funcionasse com que o
gerador e ram casa com que seu cio a sua
oficina tivesse a funcionar portanto é
toda uma dinâmica que a partida e por
fora pode por ser possível
insignificante não é é altamente
potencial não estamos sempre falando que
somos nem potenciais então o potencial
sair
aprender a ler isso estudar isso é
desenvolver isso a sofisticada e
sistemas insuficiente kang aprendendo e
sistemas nós vamos ser capazes de criar
seu contexto urbana com essas pessoas
colocou nada fazem tudo e tudo é uma
vida a sorrir a formas de poder
transformar aquilo que são as opções
urbanas das nossas cidades
eu vou construir um certo de um dos
principais organismos mundiais é um
homem que já morreu mas tem a ver com os
nossos organismos têm a ver com outra
atitude fundamental de olhar é que o
pode ser uma intervenção codificada no
contexto urbano e que o presidente o
porto neto
eu acho é e eu estamos no início do
menor mudança social e urbana que torna
necessárias mudanças nos princípios na
concessão na gestão nos instrumentos
urbanos a usar
a sociedade deve adotar novos
instrumentos para tentar dominar esta
função urbana tirando porque dela
limitando seus danos
mas para isso necessita em especial de
um novo organismo em sintonia com as
implicações e os menores dirigir
destas 10 modernidade deste concelho
modernidade fazem parte a grande maioria
das pessoas que habitam as nossas
cidades porque o dado mede deus é 21
anos e quem mais que meninos e miúdos
que são sempre tão potenciais tão
criativos estão tecnológicos estão
hipertexto sociedades hipertexto
daquelas pessoas que estão e navegavam
em várias dimensões verticais e
horizontais de suas relações com o mundo
o que o seu vizinho ocupou estados
unidos ou como disse clerum frança os
culpo o amigo que tem no chimico quem
fala no facebook e com as combinações
permanentes de ter fome sede e nós temos
um alento e um cesto potencial das
pessoas que vêm todos os dias que tem
que ser super inteligente para conseguir
sobreviver
temos também o capital desta enorme
juventudo e e dessa aceleração também
subterrânea educção das tecnologias e
redes que nós temos
ora não é para isso com certeza nessa
perspectiva desta o meu da aprendizagem
com estas pessoas que sabem tanto sobre
a vida tem tantas sugestões pra fazer
pra todos nós cidadãos a todos nós
porque sinais a todos nós decisões sobre
o sisu sobre o território
não não é isto não é isto alguém que
estava vivendo aqui algo vocês gostava
de viver aqui é que isto é uma
indignidade a emparelhada e pintada de
fresco mas não é solução para habitação
primeiro porque aqui uma questão que eu
acho que é um erro
sua conquista concerto ao o que nós
precisamos é de pessoas que construam
sua habitação construindo dentro delas
independendo nas suas presas à sua
cultura o seu modo de viver a sua
produção
muitas vezes fazem em casa por casa
muitas vezes um carro da produção em
local da comercialização não estes
buracos não estes buracos ofensivos não
a tudo isso tem que dar um clique em
cima das diversas culturas que temos que
estudar em transportar para um modo de
viver para o modo de produzir o moto
comercializados
isso é muito importante e que não é esta
a um erro estratégico em investir em
habitação e vocês vão ficar sem criar
muito espantados
mas por que esse habitação final serra
essencial da vida
sem dúvida eu ser o essencial da vida
exatamente por isso é que o estado não
deve insistir meu ou seja a única parte
em que o estado deve investir na
habitação é financeira infraestrutura
mais nada e porque isso e porque e agora
eu não é como viver e que casa é casa
a domus é um município em qualquer
pessoa investe do seu rendimento do seu
esforço do seu capital e físico
ninguém mil nós vai dar dinheiro à rua
nem vai dar dinheiro popa saio nem vai
dar dinheiro à força
não claro ainda bem que não porque não
tem crise espaço público e brunch no
mais uma pintura na nossa casa mais um
quarto de banho mais uma semita mais uma
divisão o nosso quintal
ei deixem com as pessoas
porque elas vão fazer e vamos fazer
muito melhor que esta coisa
inacreditável que estamos a fazer
deixemos deixemos deixe um só deixem só
o espaço público
deixamos uma coisa foi essencial e vi
como é que tudo precisamos de investir
não é e habitação mas em produção em
equipamentos de produção prisão porque é
muito simples nós investirmos os estados
todos os os privados e nós cidadãos
investirmos e equipamentos produtivos
estamos investindo em trabalho e sim de
trabalho estamos a conseguir rendimentos
e conseguindo rendimentos estamos a
garantir a dignidade social das pessoas
e afirmação social de aulas e o ciclo da
pobreza brasileiras é por aí porque sem
trabalho que empresas criem uma casa uma
pessoa que não tem trabalho para um
pouco mantê-la não pode sustentar a casa
não tem como dar de comer aos seus
filhos desde trabalho as pessoas for -
as pessoas costumam fazemos indústria e
elas por si próprias a partir do seu
rendimento vão conseguir com esta enorme
vitalidade tem esse enorme criatividade
esta enorme força revitalizar e autor
revitalizar a sua vida
isso é fundamental é a qualidade de vida
urbana é nossa qualidade passa para o
trabalho passa pelos equipamentos
sociais passa pelos equipamentos
produtivos no começo ajuda como é que
nós cidadãos é que podemos ajudar como é
que as instituições podem ajudar as
instituições ouvindo respeitando e
integrando as populações que têm esse
tantas e gurias nós cidadãos podemos
fazer várias coisas podemos um só
centavo se respeitá los com evidente
podemos comprar e usar os serviços do
ano nos bairros podemos ocultados
imagens de revistas fashion coisa super
bem feitas e ovar
os nossos artesãos ajudar nosso time
vários os nós só foi atos e dizer faz
nisto esse dirigente exige
profissionalismo e suficiente carlos e
profissionalizá-los e inclusivamente
quando fizemos este acontecimento também
temos não fazer ver que podemos fazê lá
no meio do cazenga por exemplo e criar
um acontecimento uma densidade estética
e uma densidade econômica que ajuda a
dinamizar e e integrará as proposições
nós todos podemos nesse comia que vem do
trabalho da renda e da produção
nós somos responsáveis por isso nós
podemos ir lá vários judar ensinado
pedir uma melhor qualidade pedir mais
mais informação crível dizer e para
fechar e vou fechar a mãe com uma
citação que enfim que é minha é nossa e
dá uns os participantes financeiros
partidos políticos partes ociosos para
artistas parque tetos engenheiros parte
de muitas partes mas nunca
especificamente nenhuma embora capazes
de contribuir para todas mas a vida é
assim a necessidade de tradução disso a
cidade assim como o pão que tem farinha
e fermento e sal e água e no fim é paulo
dá quando lá lá e pó